I test drive cars for a living
I've driven fast cars fancy cars and a
few not so fancy cars but I've never had
the chance to drive the automobile that
started at all the Model T Ford so when
I was in Detroit for the Auto Show I
took a side trip to visit the Henry Ford
Museum for a test drive of a different
kind
are you ready for our driving laughter
yes okay this is like nothing you've
ever driven before you're going to see
three petals on the floor your right
pedal is your brake the middle pedal is
reverse elect paddle is a clutch now
they call it a clutch but it doesn't
work like a standard punch that we use
today I'm going to show you how this
works I have a parking brake over here's
the gas pedal there is no gas total okay
that's a good that's a great question
how do I make it go you see this right
here this is your accelerator
so it has a ham problem there's a reason
the old-timers call it the Model T dance
getting the car to move smoothly where
you want it to go is a complicated
process so you're going to pour your
data flow you got to put your left pedal
to the floor can't give it gas all right
now put your gas up and let your left
photo well now you're in second gear
okay you're doing wonderful I have to
tell you something if you're the first
person I've ever driven with for the
very first time they did not stall the
car though very impressive the Model T
has an inline four-cylinder engine with
only 20 horsepower it could go up to 45
miles per hour if you're on a slight
downhill with the wind behind you the
normal speed for a horse and buggy is
five to eight miles per hour so this was
definitely an improvement oh and here's
one more idiosyncrasy with the Model T
the ten gallon fuel tank doesn't have a
fuel gauge on the dash so you kind of
just have to guess how far you've gone
and assume you get about 20 miles to the
gallon which it should be noted is
better gas mileage than many cars on the
road today here's the biggest surprise
the Model T is actually pretty rugged
you don't have to be precious with it it
did great in the snow Model T's were
actually made to be able to cross farms
and mountains in inclement weather you
just had to be sure to carry extra
blankets when you did it was 12 degrees
the day of my driving lesson and I was
definitely wishing the heating
technology was a little more advanced
I'm pretty sure that back in the day the
cold didn't dampen too many spirits the
quiet clicking sound the engine makes
when the car runs the wide Lake space
the comfortable leather seats and the
beautiful interior brass details all
make for a smooth fun ride it's no
surprise that Henry Ford became so
successful with his new creation this
was the car that really started it all
you